let's go
dreimal Chicken Teriyaki Menü hier ist
es das Subway Chicken Teriyaki Sub foot
long 30 cm in meiner traumkonfiguration
schauen wir mal was drauf ist das ist
auf jeden Fall ein absoluter Klassiker
ich glaube Chicken Teriyaki ist auch so
das beliebteste Sub für mich persönlich
auch der klare Favorit so wir haben
cheese original Brot Tomaten in Scheiben
Eisbergsalat ganz wichtig Chip Pole Soße
Jalapenos Gewürzgurken und natürlich
Chicken Teriyaki Fleisch das letzte Mal
haben wir den Big Mac von McDonald's
nachgemacht aber auch das hier ist
wirklich ein absoluter Klassiker und ich
bin mir sicher dass meine
Geschmacksknospen jetzt daran erinnert
werden
ist ja längst kein Geheimnis mehr das
Subway die größte Fast Food Kette der
Welt ist und das hat guten Grund das
Brot super fluffy die Saucen ganz
prägnant haben auch eine schöne Schärfe
auch die Jalapenos natürlich im Prinzip
ist das ein belegtes Brötchen aber es
schmeckt überhaupt nicht wie ein
belegtes Brötchen deshalb ist es
wirklich eine kleine Herausforderung
heute herauszufinden wie wir dieses
Ergebnis erzielen können wir wollen das
ganze heute nachmachen deshalb müssen
wir zuallererst einmal das Brot
herstellen und ich habe schon eine Idee
wie ich habe diese Backform hier einfach
ein Supermarkt gesehen für einen Zehner
und ich dachte mir das ist Schicksal so
bin ich ja noch auf die Idee gekommen
überhaupt dieses Subway Sandwich
nachzumachen wir haben genau ein Foto
einen 14 glaube ich 30,5 cm aber wir
brauchen natürlich auch den perfekten
Teig und dafür habe ich diese Zutaten
Mehl Salz Zucker Schweineschmalz
Trockenhefe Wasser Pecorino ein Ei und
Oregano ihr merkt es wir machen cheese
genau grundsätzlich dieses Rezept ist
aus vielen verschiedenen Rezepten
zusammengekommen damit wir meinen
persönliches Lieblings habt das Chicken
Teriyaki nachmachen können als erstes
nehmen wir das Wasser das habe ich so
auf 40 Grad erwärmt und geben 10 Gramm
Hefe hinein 300 Milliliter Wasser 10
Gramm Hefe das Ganze einmal schön
auflösen zack zack bisschen stehen
lassen ihr seht wie schön schaumig die
ist jetzt nehmen wir unsere trockenen
Komponenten also Mehl das sind 500 Gramm
eine Prise Salz eine doppelte Prise
Zucker in unserem Messbecher und
vermengen das ganze erstmal nur ganz
grob jetzt Schweineschmalz dazu könnt
ihr auch einfach Butter benutzen oder
Olivenöl oder was auch immer irgendwie
Fett und wir lassen das Ganze verrühren
wenn der schmalz in unseren trockenteig
integriert ist geben wir die Hefe hinzu
und rühren die langsam unter lassen das
Ganze dann eine Weile kneten so dass der
Teig auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen
gearbeitet hat trink keinen Bäcker aber
wir gucken uns das mal an und das wird
schon klappen
Leute ich bin ganz ehrlich ich bin ein
bisschen stolz ich bin ein bisschen ein
kleiner stolzer Teig Papa hier gerade
geworden das sieht richtig gut aus also
der ist so ein bisschen klebrig noch
aber ich glaube das ist nicht weiter
schlimm den sollen wir auf jeden Fall
jetzt irgendwie in Form einer Kugel
bekommen einmal gelernt von Pizzateig
bei jedem Teig angewendet jetzt Trick
backtrennspray auch auf die
frischhaltefolge sprühen am besten nicht
auf die Ränder damit die trotzdem noch
greift und das ganze abdecken das lasse
ich jetzt so für eine Stunde ruhen und
in der Zeit kümmern wir uns schon mal um
unser Chicken Teriyaki los geht's und
das besteht natürlich aus chicken hier
haben wir Hähnchenbrust und der Soße
Teriyaki Soße die besteht aus Ingwer
Knoblauch Rohrzucker Mirin Sake und
Sojasoße ich schneide jetzt mal
knoblauch und Ingwer klein währenddessen
heiß unsere Pflanze vor wir gehen mit
ein bisschen Olivenöl in unsere
Hühnerbrust der wir teilweise Butterfly
aufgeschnitten so dass die schön
gleichmäßig durchdreht und jetzt
massiere ich das Öl einfach ein
natürlich nicht nee danach Hände waschen
sie ist das ihr wisst Bescheid ein
bisschen Salz Pfeffer dran und dann
schön auf hoher Hitze anbraten von
beiden Seiten so dass das Fleisch
versiegelt innen drin aber saftig bleibt
wir platzieren die Hühnerbrust dass sie
schön viel Kontakt hat und Braten das
Ganze einmal durch und dann wenden wir
das ganze auch schon hier sieht man es
in echt schöne Röster rum angekommen so
wenn unser chicken fertig gebraten ist
können wir uns auch weiter um die Soße
kümmern ich gebe das hier einfach mal
zur Seite kannst du ein bisschen gar
ziehen und mit der Soße ist es ganz
einfach wir nehmen uns ein bisschen
Sesamöl in die Pfanne muss man ein
bisschen asiatischen Supermarkt für
auseinander nehmen für die Soße aber es
lohnt sich als ich den Big Mac das
letzte Mal nachgemacht habe habe ich mir
gedacht krank wie nass schmeckt diese
Soße bitte ich bin gespannt wie das
Rezept ist was wir heute raussuchen die
ganze Küche duftet schon nach dem
Sesamöl da rein gebe ich jetzt eine
geriebene Knoblauchzehe ein bisschen
heiß und ein wenig Ingwer auch gerieben
nicht zu heiß machen das Ganze nur ein
bisschen anbraten ich nehme jetzt gerade
von der Hitze runter befindet sich
direkt sehr schön vor der Geruch ne
Sesamöl Knoblauch irgendwann man riecht
wirklich schon Geschmack in der Luft und
vor allem das gerieben ne lässt das
Gleichheit perfekt in der ganzen Soße
untergehen ne ja jetzt gebe ich dazu
Rohrzucker den ich einfach ein bisschen
an Schmelze bisschen karamellisieren und
wenn der geschmolzen ist löschen wir das
Ganze ab und jetzt ist alles was wir tun
müssen einfach zake Mirin und Sojasauce
drauf zu schütten das ganze kochen wir
jetzt ein bisschen so dass der Zucker
schmilzt und das ganze ein bisschen
einreduziert so unsere Soße ist auf
jeden Fall schon ordentlich eingedickt
und schmeckt vor allem ultra gut ich
möchte die aber noch weiter eindicken
weil bei Subway ist ja schon fast so ein
bisschen schleimig ich weiß dass wenn
man nicht hören wenn man es ist aber
irgendwie macht das auch was aus deshalb
gehe ich jetzt mit ein bisschen
Speisestärke und Wasser einfach noch mal
ran so dass es halt einfach noch weiter
eindecken kann sowieso wenn man was
eindickt immer tendenziell weniger dazu
tun und abwarten weil die Zeit arbeitet
auch wenn die gewünschte Konsistenz
erreicht ist machen wir die Hitze aus
und schneiden jetzt unser chicken aber
nicht irgendwie sondern wir wollen auch
das natürlich so komplett im Subway
Style haben für Papiere ich einfach mal
so eine Butterfly geschnittene
Hähnchenbrust und macht dann so Streifen
daraus jetzt nehmen wir unser
geschnittenes chicken wir müssen eine
Schüssel mitsamt seinem Saft und
Tränken das ganze in unserer schönen
angedickten Teriyaki Soße boah das ist
auf jeden Fall jede Menge Geschmack der
daran kommt wichtig so viel Soße dass
das richtig schön da drin schwimmt oder
saugt sich jetzt voll mit dem Geschmack
so dass wir am Ende geil mariniertes
chicken haben wow eine Stunde ist
vergangen und das ist unser Teig jetzt
wir sind jetzt lecker wir sind lecker
ich glaube auch so macht Spaß so macht
Spaß
da ist das Ding und ja dritten würde ich
sagen mal so das heißt ein Drittel drei
Drittel auf einmal das nehmen wir jetzt
und Formen daraus schöne Röllchen
und rein jetzt habe ich hier noch ein
feuchtes Tuch und deckt das ganze
einfach lose ab für fünf bis zehn
Minuten das Brot ist schon schön
aufgegangen jetzt kümmern wir uns um die
Chip Pole Sauce ganz einfach wir nehmen
natürlich chiphole Chilis gehen wir rein
drei Stück an der Zahl die sind quasi in
Adobe Soße mariniert gewesen von der
Adobe Soße nehmen wir auch noch mal die
Teelöffel rein das ist die Dose die wir
gefunden haben generell sind die positiv
ist glaube ich nicht super einfach zu
bekommen aber man braucht sie einfach
für diesen rauchigen Geschmack weiteren
rauchigen Geschmack holen wir uns durch
geräucherte Paprika davon einfach so
zwei Teelöffel das wird wirklich super
rauchig schmecken wir gehen jetzt auch
mit jeder Menge Majoran 250 Gramm Mario
keine Sorge das brauchen wir nicht alles
für unser Tab sondern ihr habt danach
eine schöne selbstgemachte Mario Ketchup
dran 40 Gramm dann noch 10 Gramm Senf
grober sind die schon am besten und den
Saft von einer halben Zitrone und all
das Pürieren wir jetzt einfach einmal
schön durch
wow ich glaube das ist Soße
übelst geil
richtig richtig lecker ich sag mal so
das Ding im Kühlschrank stehen zu haben
ist auf jeden Fall auch nicht verkehrt
und so sieht unser Teig jetzt aus sehr
schön bisschen ungleichförmig aber es
ist homemade ist okay wir gehen jetzt
rein mit einem verkürten Ei mit einem
Schuss Wasser und bepinseln unsere
brotte und jetzt gehen wir einfach mit
ein bisschen Oregano ran riecht halt
wirklich auch schon wie so ein Subway
Brot das streue ich jetzt hier
vorsichtig drauf das nicht allzu viel
drauf ist aber einfach so für den
typischen Look und Geschmack was auch
nicht fehlen darf ist der cheese
natürlich da streuen wir ein bisschen
von drüber das ganze geben jetzt
vorsichtig in unseren Backofen ich habe
ja ein Dampfbackofen den habe ich auch
angestellt und quasi so eine Dampf
Funktion wenn ihr das nicht habt 190
Grad Umluft und eine Pfanne mit
kochendem Wasser einfach unten
reinstellen funktioniert genauso gut
jetzt schieben wir das ganze in den
Backofen checken nach 10 Minuten mal wie
es aus ist duftet direkt nach cheese
oder genau sehr sehr gespannt ich auch
hier riecht es einfach eins zu eins wie
bei Subway es ist unglaublich ne glaube
ich kann meine
Begeisterung schlecht verbergen gerade
wir haben das Subway Rezept uns
angeschaut und wir wollen 200 Grad
interne Tipps also jetzt klappt aber
auch alles oder in dem Moment wo wir
testen haben wir 204 Grad Fahrenheit in
der Mitte Alter let's go okay Brote sind
fertig die holen wir jetzt draußen
lassen sie schön Abkühlen herzlich
willkommen in meinem eigenen Subway ich
habe Brot ich habe Chicken Teriyaki ich
habe alle anderen Zutaten selbstgemachte
aber bevor es ans anrichten geht eine
kurze wichtige Info von mir selbst es
gibt ein großes Projekt an dem ich
arbeite und die allerersten
Informationen sind jetzt im Internet
guckt einfach mal bei blog.shop auf
Instagram vorbei oder geht auf die
Website blocken im Shop das ist alles
was ich sagen will dauert noch ein
bisschen damit wirklich an die
Öffentlichkeit gehen kann aber es wird
geil okay machen
also ich möchte gerne einen Chicken
Teriyaki auf real,- wir nehmen das Brot
schief anschneiden so natürlich nicht zu
tief soll noch ein Tag bleiben da hätten
wir es einmal hier ist unser Backpapier
chicken Chicken Teriyaki mit
Scheibenkäse bitte habe ich acht super
habe ich gerade frisch mariniert und
Scheibenkäse habe ich auch da ich gebe
das kurz in meinen megaofen rein welches
Gemüse war das bei Dir machst du bitte
Salat
Tomate Gurke Zwiebel bisschen kalabrenno
ein bisschen eingelegte Gurke ach krass
habe ich alles da ja
auch eine negative Bewertung geschrieben
ist vollkommen in Ordnung mein lieber
lass mir Moment Zeit ich bin noch neu
hier so ein paar Gurken noch für dich
mein lieber ne Soße mache ich chipotel
alles
[Applaus]
boah das ist ja originale Sound gewesen
oder wir klappen das ganze einfach zu
und ich rolle es direkt hier so ein
bisschen auf und dann von den Seiten
rein und jetzt schön eng Rollen ich bin
sehr gespannt wie es schmeckt all die
Arbeit das war schon viel Arbeit sind
das war so ein 5 Stunden Projekt aber
wir haben natürlich auch gefilmt aber es
muss auch gut schmecken also schneiden
wir zu allererst einmal den Klassiker an
schicken Teriyaki von Subway absoluter
Klassiker in Anblick den ihr vielleicht
schon kennt innen drin haben wir die
Füllung schicken Teriyaki alles was wir
sonst so bestellt haben wir schneiden
auch das hier einmal auseinander und
hier ist unser eigenes okay Teriyaki SAP
Marine Sandro das sieht sehr gut aus
ganz ehrlich side-by-side finde ich
sieht unseres einfach so ein bisschen
kompakter und frischer aus weiß ich auch
nicht genau wir probieren noch mal den
Klassiker Attacke
so schmeckt es ich habe sie erst vor
einer Stunde gegessen deswegen Anfang
des Videos gedreht haben das schmeckt
genauso wie das andere in dass ich heute
rein gebissen habe zu jedes ist jedes
Mal immer wieder gleich wie nah kommen
wir an diesem charakteristischen
typischen Geschmack mit unserer
selbstgemachten Version selbstgemachtes
Sub selbstgemachtes selbst mariniertes
chicken ich probiere ich wirklich ich
habe hart gearbeitet für diesen Moment
deshalb genießen wir ihn
boah krass das Fleisch schmeckt in so
einem Sub wirklich sehr sehr sehr
ähnlich Unterschiede sind da das Brot
nimmt eine ganz andere Rolle ein bei
Subway verschwindet das Brot hier hast
du sogar so ein bisschen so ein knack
vom Brot ich persönlich finde das
richtig geil Soße schmeckt genau gleich
aber das schicken ist perfekt das hier
schmeckt eigentlich nicht nach Fast Food
das schmeckt wie so ein frisches geiles
Baguette ich würde sagen das war ein
absoluter Erfolg das war auch mehreren
Erfolg als der Big Mac weil wir wollen
ja nachmachen wir wollen es ja nicht
einfach nur besser machen und hier sind
wir auf jeden Fall ziemlich ziemlich nah
ans Original gekommen man kann auch bei
Rewe meinte Erik so fertige Baguette
Brote holen quasi damit spart man sich
ein zwei Stunden Arbeit mit dem Brot und
man hat glaube ich dann wirklich etwas
was sehr sehr sehr nah daran kommt wir
wollten das Brot selbst machen hat sich
auch absolut gelohnt was soll ich sagen
Leute ich hoffe das Video hat euch Spaß
gemacht wir hatten sehr großen Spaß beim
Drehen und schreibt in die Kommentare
was wir als nächstes nachmachen sollen
schaut gerne hier oben vorbei den Kanal
zu abonnieren hier unten ist ein für
dich persönlich vorgeschlagenes video
sehen uns dann bis dahin ciao ciao